a fait une compilation de toutes vos
aventures regardez julien en fait il a
fait comme le bachelor mais en plusieurs
étapes quoi ces souks et des tee-shirts
moi je suis d'abord la partie des belles
gens qui mangent entre nous je pense que
jetons
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
et là et julien vous avez trouvé l'amour
grâce aux émissions de télé-réalité en
fait c'est ça vous avez vous êtes tombé
amoureux d'ilona candidat c'est ça
l'année dernière au cours d'une aventure
qui s'appelle les princes de l'amour et
la cb depuis deux chiens romilly romeo
voyage à bali
vous avez fait 2 j me demandant mon
premier de sa poule et ses magnifiques
voix de deux chiens ouais ouais c'est ça
écoute j'ai demandé sa main il ya deux
semaines dieu bénisse elle a dit oui à
baba boucalo belle histoire
vous ne regrettez pas vous avez hélas
vraiment vous avez chanté que c'est la
femme de votre vie ouais c'est des trucs
ça s'explique pas je sais s'il veut pas
dire c'est une magie un truc qui te
prends tu vois si c'est comme ça c'est
fort